yeah welcome to this video with step by
step
yeah frequent opponent and not a very
comfortable one I usually have problems
against the Scott I really have a bad
squad six and a half out of 19 let's see
yeah yeah this is some Queens gambit
accepted my wonder this is this a
position where I can peek with the night
hmm I have not shown any pawn takes is
very normal but I wasn't really sure
here okay
so 95 looks quite normal
[Music]
yeah but how do I play this him yeah
well it's just a very normal way to do
it with with Bishop back at Queen d3
maybe yeah maybe yeah he also have Queen
before that this is answered by a5 which
looks a bit awkward I can play
hmm yeah I can always I can also play
Queen h5 and go further for the
sacrifices g6 bishop g6 hmm it's not not
quite sure that it's just work
also NYCHA's sexism queenie for that's
f5 that's not not really going to work i
can retreat the bishop but he has night
before
okay so okay he didn't play g6 but f5
okay so if I take it seven I have to
reckon with Knight f4 but I probably
still have to do it don't really see an
alternative
okay so Knight coming to f4 possibly I
can just take on d5 as a simple move
that probably should do that okay so how
would I play here yes possible Queen B
form which is possibly awkward attacking
indeed from b24
my queen nia is a bit offside not sure
that it should it should stay there
let's just go back here Oh Queen g5 why
am I playing nonsense move against the
sky all the time I really don't
understand that there are some people
where you just plain nonsense against
yeah this is yeah great great g2 and
someone just just a very simple double
attack
[Applause]
okay there's some way to continue this F
form check okay man can I give do
something I mean okay I'm just two pawns
down him if he's not making a mistake
I'm just losing and quite typical I
already had a nice position before i
blundered pretty sure that was was was
quite good I mean not like I was winning
and you think but it was it was quite
nice actually
okay so Knight is there some tricks that
I can go for I can do this and send his
knight a bit off site says some way with
97 maybe 97 rook t8 maybe this I don't
know don't really see something great
[Music]
I take 97 and isn't is it uncomfortable
for Queenie six
we need six check and then 95 maybe
what about f3 can you do that I'm a kid
poor I could take with the pawn it's not
helping him a lot yeah he let me back
into the game I think yeah recruit yet
Queen e6 check King back 95 and I'm
winning early 95 is such a huge news
night f7 is a isn't as a great pin and
I'm threatening Queenie 6-year not yeah
check okay so after night f7 and to have
the time double check I can also just
take t5 maybe this is in fact easiest
and let's do that I don't have much time
anyway also checking the night
maybe rookie aid but I can play Knight
f7 double-check Quincy a check and rupee
one that's not working
Jackie check okay if he goes to a change
check she doesn't check check
Kings is seven rook t7s winning the
Queen at least maybe I'm checking my
gang somehow but winning the Queen is
good check black resigned
yeah I was extremely lucky just overlook
the Queen g5 move here I think I'm
really I'm okay yeah I mean I should
never be worse Queen e2 is in general
not not a bad idea I had to get the
Queen back from h5 but I just over I
mean I immediately saw it of course as
as it happens so often you play a
blunder and you see it right away yeah
this just it's just bad I could have
played Queen f1 which I didn't even see
hmm
wow that was a bad game instead I gave
away those pawns here but then he
completely completely blundered the game
back I guess f4 yeah this is this is
losing computers giving +2 now what he
the very best defends us giving away the
rook and avoiding the direct direct
checkmate and young I'm really just
winning Queen d5 and check exactly like
that I'm ruining check yeah I mean he
could have gone here this is a bit
tougher because here it looks like a
perpetual but I can do their self it's
quite neat covering those two squares
and then take here this this would have
been interesting in fact from a
technical point of view if I would have
managed that in the time okay but I had
40 seconds probably I would have check
check this is much much easier of course
check check okay
I wrote the ADA's in fact meet yeah I
didn't see that jockey aid check me and
made but okay if you can win the Queen
without any kind of problem let's just
let's just take it yeah and be be fine
with it
okay he was lucky thanks for watching